nearly a week after her son was hit by a
car a local woman is sharing his story
police say the 21 year old was riding
his electric scooter to work in the
southwest Valley when everything changed
he's now fighting to survive at UMC
that's where we find Sasha Loftus live
with more on the Family's message
Brian the woman I spoke with says her
son who is also a father himself has
been here at UMC fighting to survive as
you said since he would it was hit last
Thursday she hopes sharing his story
will encourage other drivers to be more
aware
it doesn't make sense a devastated
mother shares everything she loves about
her son he's loving he's caring he's
funny he likes to crack jokes Julio
vadoy Jr was riding his electric scooter
to work last Thursday afternoon when he
was hit by a car in this crosswalk at
Mountain's Edge Parkway and Durango in
the southwest Valley my kids went
looking for him and seen Channel 8 news
seen the police tape see my son scooter
on the road he's now fighting to survive
here at UMC just off life support with
swelling and bleeding in his brain my
healthy 21 year old boy is laying in a
hospital bed and can't do nothing for
himself police say the person who hit
Julio stayed on scene and didn't show
any signs of impairment but his mom
Jamie Utterback says she's sick of
seeing crashes like this and wants to
see some traffic changes in the area he
was doing nothing wrong he was on his
way to work
I want answers
to how this happened and she's using
every ounce of strength she has hoping
her child and her entire family can
recover and move forward it's
heartbreaking
it's so heartbreaking
now Jamie says there's no real timeline
of her son's recovery and the family has
set up a GoFundMe to help with medical
bills and other expenses if you'd like
to help we have a link to that on our
website 8newsnow.com reporting live
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now